*Sexualized Moan*
Hoh! Hmm!!!
E-heh?!
You ever see something online and you make that exact expression? Well then this video is for you. Prepare to get your best
"hmm" face on cause you're-- we're about to go on a
"hmm" journey where we gonna "hmm" at things. Is this joke getting old? Yes, it is already. Great.
Hmmmm...
Hmm
That is very interesting
The men are having fun in the-- in the living room while the women is doing the dishes
Hmm... hmmmmmm...
It's interesting how back in the days we were so wrong. Look how wrong we were. Hmm! Very interesting
So dumb.
Well I guess houses need electricity too
Interesting. It all makes sense. That is not "hmm", that is
disgusting. That's disgusting. Take it away from me, please
Mmm. What? Pancake, the classic one-in-a-row game.
That's not that that's a Photoshop, that's not real. I'm not gonna "hmm" at that one, that's a faker. That's not
"hmm"-worthy at all
Huh
Uhh, that's not huh "hmm", that's "hmmmm"... "Is this real? Why does it look so weird?"
"The mirror is curved."
OHHHHH
Why, of course!
HMMMMMMMMMMMM!
Look everyone it's YouTuber high school. Look at all these normals look at their fuckin' haircuts
Good one. Why? Just why? Why? Can I ask that at least?
Hmm, now I see it
Hmm, what is happening here? That man is invisible. But if he's invisible then why is he wearing clothing?
Oh the socks, it's the socks, okay, I get it. It was the socks all along. Hilarious.
Now that's...
Absolute mad lad. Why would anyone do that? I wonder what a chair tastes like... hmmmmmm!
Who would ever know? Have you ever tried a chair?
Oh
It took me so long. Cause he's a puppet, right? I didn't really watch Muppets as a kid. They scare me
Now that's "hmm"
Was Lincoln an alien all along maybe perhaps, I think yes, yes confirmed
Mmm now that's, that's a radiator
Hmm, I don't believe that is actually a
functioning light I believe that's
Indeed a basketball, a basketball inside the light. Very interesting. Well done, well played.
That is not a laptop. That is a toast-making machine
Or is it?
Hmm. "We've all had this mistake at least once rushed out the door and grabbed the panini press instead of the laptop"
It happens to the best of us, it truly does. But at least you get to do some delicious toast while you're at school
It's a USB into a USB charger. I've infiltrated the system
I wonder actually what would happen what would happen you have those self-destructing USBs, right?
But where does it end?
Did the pencil become a teacher or did the teacher become a pencil?
There is no teacher.
I need to do this next time I'm in Italy
So cute :3
That's just a funny idea, I don't know. That's not-- that doesn't make me "hmm", okay? That does *not* make me "hmm"
I wanna be "hmm"!
Is that a Photoshop? No way.
That slice of banana looks just like the dog. Is the dog the banana?
Reincarnated soul? Perhaps
What... am I looking at?
Elmo please! Stop! This is not "hmm" this is "hmmMM"
Do you ever hate when you take off your sweater
and you realize your legs go all the way up into your-- your chin? Wait. I can just click there? I had no idea
Seriously I didn't never knew how to use reddit before. Jesus
Hummm!
That man is turning to uh
Wood! Oh my god, that's disgusting
but also hmmm
What the hell is with this picture?!
Stop!
This is a cursed image. This is not making me hmm. That's making me eugh!
Dogs can't take selfies, everyone knows that
Stop looking at me
Yes, maybe he did run off to South Africa and took some age-reducing
drugs and came back to the New York subway
Hmmmm. It *is* possible if you think about it... not too hard.
Why? I love the girl's reaction. What is that? Why? What's the point?
Hmmmmm! Truly making you think here on the PewDiePie channel, truly making you elevate your mind.
Do you feel like you're being exercised? Not a lot of people would understand pictures like this, but not the hmm-ers
*chuckle*
Hmmmm
Oh my god, there's a cat inside the cat! Hmm!
I'm getting really tired of hmm-ing in every single picture
I mean that just make sense, I would do the same thing, but then again... why would you need the chair in the first place?
HummMMMM!
Oh, I've seen this one
Wow, some delicious Maltesers
Hmmmm. Still delicious of course. Alright here we have Ed Sheeran
I thought it was leaves. I've always had my suspect-- suspicions that Ed Sheeran had an army of leaves
with his own face on it, but now -- hmm --
it's confirmed
That is so sweet she's finally going to get a nose
Hmmm, isn't it wonderful when people --
hmm! -- get a nose
That's just a great Photoshop, I don't know what else to say about that one
It's kinda cute.
What am I looking at, what is this? I mean: hmmmm!
Can statues actually say no to cigarettes? How interesting
How did that happen?
Maybe you get smarter once you get your passport. That's what it is. "Where do you work out?"
"At the library."
I wonder who this lady is cause the face is blurred.
Hmmmm...
I need to get this. I need to get this haircut, please. How can I do it, huh? Is it possible?
Probably not
But hmmmm
Wow!
That's an interesting face makeup.
Okay, I think, I think that was enough hmm-ing today
Let me know in the comments: what makes you "hmmmmmmm"?
Or perhaps "hmmm". Or maybe you're more of a "hmmMM"
Hmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmm!